we'll take a deeper look now at the
Trump administration's trade in tariff
policies with two guests at the table
with some differing viewpoints one of
them is a Veronique de Russia of the
George Mason University's Mercatus
Center she is a senior research fellow
thank you for being here we also welcome
Scott Paul president of the Alliance for
American manufacturing thank you for
being here
good to be with you I wanted to start
with your your takeaways from day one of
this g7 meeting in Quebec and what you'd
be looking for today
Scott Paul why don't we start with you I
don't expect much there are clear
differences that the president Trump has
articulated and there obviously is some
resistance to that from the rest of the
g7 I think that something that they all
can come to agree on and this is one of
the understated goals of the
administration policy is how to confront
China and its state-led capitalism it's
I think it's a common interest that they
all have and I don't know if they're
going to be able to pivot to that given
some of the rhetoric that we've seen the
last few days but that would that would
be a reasonably good outcome there any
perspective very dear Jay I I agree
we've got that one of the things that
they should be able to agree with one
another about is what to do with China
this is by the way this is their way to
do all about China as you view you
create an alliance of like-minded
countries and you you deal with it
together but the rhetoric and the the
rhetoric from the Trump administration
and and basically the aggressiveness and
some very unorthodox moves in the recent
month actually it's been going on for
four months I think make it very
difficult but the phone numbers on the
bottom of the screen for our guests for
this hour as we talk about Trump
administration trade and tariff policies
will get to your calls in just a couple
of minutes for our two guest Scott Paul
who is president of the Alliance for
American manufacturing and Veronique
J who is senior research fellow at the
Mercatus Center at George Mason
University before we dig in deeper to
the issues at hand
give us some 101 here explained for us
Veronique darou Jay what exactly are
tariffs how do they work and and why are
they an so important that we're talking
about them this morning
so tariffs are effectively an import tax
that's what they are it's an import tax
and so the their stated goal is to
impose a penalty on imports but and also
to achieve several goals sometimes is to
retaliate at the stated goals right to
retaliate against foreign governments
behavior in subsidizing their goods or
or to protect a domestic industry that's
there because of course if you put if
you increase the price of something in
theory the we're not in theory the
demand will well will go down unless
people have no choice in reality however
I mean the the effective effect that
tariffs have even though they are all
you know when when when government
imposes impose a tariff it talks about
trying to address something for another
government what ends up happening is
that it actually penalized as domestic
consumers because precisely it increases
the cost of of that particular good
meaning that that choice is either not
available anymore or is available but at
a much higher price
it's got Paul pick up in that point
about consumers and bring this home for
people like me and you and Veronique and
folks at home the viewers what do these
tariffs mean in the store for people and
in their pocketbooks
I think the honest answer is it not all
that much in an economy that's 19
trillion dollars the steel and aluminum
tariffs if they were to fully take
effect would amount to somewhere
depending on the price of the good
between six and nine
million dollars again that's in a
nineteen trillion dollar economy the you
know Wilbur Ross the Commerce Secretary
I think had a made a demonstration of
this with an aluminum can and a beer and
a Campbell Soup can and and yes it
looked kind of silly but the but I think
the point was very valid is that the the
consumer would see a negligible effect
from all of this meanwhile you would see
and you have more steel mills more
aluminum smelters open in the United
States you'd seen you would see these
companies recover more of their market
share and have that have that level of
business where they're able to sustain
it to provide good middle-class jobs and
to provide for our national defense as
well let's get a response
well actually I disagree I mean I
actually think wellbore Ross's
demonstration with the can was was
extremely silly and spent debunked that
numbers have been debunked quite
extensively but more importantly if the
point is it's it's wrong and misleading
to actually look at the impact of
tariffs on the overall US economy which
is gigantic you're right what is
important is especially because what
people may not realize is the trade
represents a third right and of our
economy and still in aluminum is only a
small part of this what is important to
look at if you really want to know what
it means
one you look at the downstream effect of
these tariffs for companies and so
consumers of steel and aluminum and they
are facing when they cannot shift to an
American steel or when they cannot do
away with something else with with still
they face immediately in the case of
still a 25% increase these these
consumers are still you if you want a
demonstration if you want a
heartbreaking demonstration about who is
getting hurt there are American workers
and company that is consumed steel go
look at because you you probably know
that the president Trump has they've
decided to give X Tempah tential II and
go look and read the stories of all
these little companies with rain
sharp margins who are asking begging the
government their government to not hurt
them and get them out of business
there so you can read it's it's on the
website and you can read the case they
make they say they say we import
European still that specialty still that
is not available in the US so instantly
we have to to face an increase in cost
quite significant before we go to calls
one more thought for mr. butcher well
there is a product exclusion process so
if if a steel or aluminum product isn't
available in the United States a company
can petition to have it brought in and
be exempt from the duties that's point
number one
I think point number two is that there's
no macro evidence that this is having an
impact so far in fact you've seen
employment and manufacturing and
including in metal consuming industries
continue to rise that's a pretty good
sign and on the flip side of this and I
think this is an important factor I mean
when you've seen the the price of steel
and aluminum drop precipitously because
of China's market distorting activities
you haven't seen those savings passed
directly along to consumers the
businesses have kept those so they're
sitting on top of 1.5 trillion dollars
in tax cut savings they've certainly
accrued some profits and savings through
through through purchasing this dumped
and subsidized steel and so I I do I
think have a lot of empathy for some of
these adjustment issues but it does work
both ways just really is an experience
if you want to know the cost of steel
tariffs we can look at 2002 studies done
like the best studies out there showed
that the price of steel went up which is
is to be expected unemployment by all
account on in the steel industry went up
just either either zero or by a thousand
jobs yeah we can just cheer this but the
loss and still consuming industries
could have been up to two hundred
thousand jobs which is there are a
hundred forty thousand jobs in this
steel in
so there's been more and this is the
reason why the the Bush administration
at the time because there was in 2002 we
had said the tariffs for several years
and after a year they said enough let me
jump in and start with calls Ralph
you've been hanging on patiently from
Kalamazoo Michigan on the line for
Democrats you're on the air yes it looks
like we're realigning Trump is
realigning our trade and economic
interest with Russia and rejecting
Europe and Canada and Mexico which is
our traditional trading partners and our
traditional political lines so could
could maybe the guys former Cadis could
explain to me the trading relationship
we have with Russia like what do they
produce and what kind of economy like
what do we buy from them what do we sell
to them and maybe you can describe what
kind of economy the Russians have my
understanding it's a totally corrupt
kleptocracy where a few billionaires run
everything they sort of have a semi
state monopoly which is run by Vladimir
Putin which is really not a free market
so maybe he can explain what we get from
Russia and what the relationship we have
this new new relationship with Russia
was invading all these countries it has
this great kept on Chrystie which i
guess most of the people in russia are
poor thanks for calling ralph the guy is
Scott Paul he's actually with the
Alliance for American manufacturing you
want to take that question from from our
guest sure caller sure
so first of all I think that Russia is
not a model economy and I don't think
that there's much of a benefit to closer
Tice unless they make some serious
political and economic reforms trade is
heavily in commodities with Russia they
also have a state driven steel industry
that's a major problem for the United
States and I believe Russia should be a
target of this and I will say you know I
know I don't agree with the president's
approach approach with respect to our
allies I do think that they should be
engaged as full partners in this I think
we need steel and aluminum tariffs more
broadly I think we need to get out of
the overcapacity in the steel industry
that's been generated by
a China and I I don't agree with every
tactic that the president has had here
but this is a rebalancing that has been
long overdue to Veronique de Roos a of
the Mercatus Center what did you make of
the president's thought about getting
Russia back into the g7 you know I I
have to be honest I didn't think very
much because President Trump is known
for you know making comments you know
just like this he'll he'll say this and
who knows where he'll stand tomorrow and
but I totally agree with with Scott that
the approach to our allies and the use
of the starett tickets so you can debate
the economics of still in aluminum
tariffs but and and and and I disagree i
think it's it's hurtful to the american
people and it's the US government
hurting the american people but there's
something where I think there's somewhat
of an understanding and and a shock in
in the community of economists and and
people who think about these issues the
means that were used to actually impose
these tariffs using a national security
threat argument and using the section
232 to target our NATO allies is is is
problematic we'll get back to that
section 232 argument want to get Tom and
though from Pompano Beach Republican
caller for our guests on trade and
tariffs hi Tom hi thank you for taking
my call you're welcome well this is real
interesting you know I invite anybody
that's against Trump in his trade
policies and trying to change them to
take a ride through the Midwest and look
at all the ghost towns over there what
with NAFTA and the World Trade
Organization it's about time I'm just
sorry that it's 30 years too late for me
but we have a generation of people here
that actually do want to work and make
decent money and there's so many people
out there that hate Trump no matter what
he does no matter what he does they hate
him and it's just sad to see what these
people
like this Veronica talking about you
know small numbers take a right to the
Midwest see what these countries great
Canada and Mexico have done to our
country and you want to just keep it on
is there anybody that thinks that this
is just wonderful the way it is thanks
Tom in South Florida I want to respond
to that so I mean I sympathize with
Tom's feeling but the the thing is like
the problem with trade is like people
first tend to see the cost of trade and
sometime they really miss assigned cost
to trade and they don't see also the
benefits the benefits to consumers in
the US and usually often lower income
consumers but there is also important
that is very important to make which is
that a lot of the jobs for instance take
steel you know when steel employment
peaked in the u.s. in 1953 there was
650,000 jobs in the steel industry and
it started declining and experts agreed
because of labor-saving innovations
right and now we have a hundred forty
thousand jobs in the steel industry and
highly productive jobs which is why
they're highly paid and so it's that the
decline in the steel industry and all
other manufacturing by the way this is a
pattern that can be reproduced for all
manufacturing jobs started long before
NAFTA long before the WTO and and if you
want to think about just even the the
Chinese getting into the WTO the top
number four job loss to the competition
was China since the since the WTO
entrance is the four million dollars for
four million jobs which is a high number
well every month in the US there is a
turn if there's a turn of close to two
million jobs right so we tend to blame
trade and some of it is true but but
it's it's easy to point the finger at
trade but it's sometimes misdirected and
unfortunately when
misdirect the the problems we tend to
have the wrong solutions let's get Jean
into the conversation Bowie Maryland
Democratic caller for our gasps good
morning Jean good morning yes
my concern is a presentation on book TV
recently concerning the two decades of
increasing manufacturer of some
pharmaceuticals by China
the book was of three years of research
and the panel included an international
banker and an economist who were all
agreed that more than 20,000 facilities
over the last two decades of
pharmaceutical manufacturing the United
States had gone to everything vanished
and moved over to China including a
major facilities of Pfizer including the
best R&D facilities and the concern is
one of my concerns is I haven't know
about ten years ago researchers at Johns
Hopkins found out that dose one of the
one of these medicines that has gone
from us I believe I got it correctly
that not one milligram a person are
heparin for example and not being
produced in the United States and about
ten years ago a researcher at Hopkins
found out looking at tested the heparin
come from China and something in the
order of 20% were not heparin now they
did say that many of their manufacturing
facilities are excellent but many are
not so good and we cannot control the
quality so my suggestion is would it be
a reasonable law to have a label saying
all our pharmaceuticals saying active
ingredients manufactured in USA China
Japan wherever is that too asking too
much to know where our active
ingredients in a pharmaceutical pian
manufacture that was Jean from Maryland
scott Paul's with the Alliance for
American manufacturing what do you make
of what he said so Jean I'm I'm familiar
with this pharmaceutical issue and I I'm
someone who believes that transparency
for consumers is a good thing so the
more labeling the better and let the
consumer decide what kind of values are
important to them in addition to the
price there is a legitimate concern
about the concentration of
pharmaceuticals
in China both from monopolistic point of
view and also from a quality control
point of view and so I don't think that
I don't believe I'm not someone who
believes that all imports are bad by any
means but I do think there needs to be
rigorous Quality Assurance and I do
think that there is some danger to have
manufacturer of some product when
there's not a reason for it like the
mineral deposit is not all in that
country to be concentrated in a country
like that I think having diversity of
supply is generally a very good thing
and Judith is in Austin Texas
independent caller hi Judith hi I was
wondering am I wrong isn't the Pentagon
our greatest user of imported aluminum
and steel anybody know the answer to
that I don't know what I know is the
Pentagon stated that its needs for steel
and aluminum was was widely provided was
more than provided by domestic steel so
Judith why do you bring it up well
because I thought that it was going to
affect the Pentagon know the tariff on
that but if it's important I mean if its
domestic then it doesn't apply thanks
Judith so I'll say there are laws
procurement laws that require the
defense contracts to buy American steel
and aluminum and there are some
exceptions to that but not many the
challenge is that there are only a
couple of factories left in the United
States and these have been hollowed out
this is not about productivity these
have been hollowed out one that makes
armor plate steel that's capable of
providing the up armor for the armored
personnel carrier carriers that we have
and say Afghanistan or Iraq there's one
producer left of grain oriented
electrical steel which is important in a
lot of very sophisticated applications
and there's one producer of high purity
aluminum that goes into our aircraft and
so there is a legitimate national
security concern about having enough of
this supply and well I don't disagree
that you know that you can look at
supply from Canada and say I think that
that makes a lot of sense to incorporate
into our national security thinking I
think outside of that it's very
difficult you know we were woefully
unprepared headed into World War two
hopefully we don't have any future
conflicts that even approach that a
reason why we were able to respond to
that is that we had an enormous defense
industrial base and it was able to to
recalibrate and produce the arsenal of
democracy we don't have that capability
today yeah in things like steel and
aluminum and sophisticated electronics
we are very dependent on imported
sources for all of that I did want you
to help us understand section 232 a
little bit better of the trade expansion
act it says in part that a provision or
it's a provision of the 1962 law that
gives the white house broad flexibility
to impose and adjust tariffs exactly
with exempting some trade partners along
the way based on these national security
concerns how has the president been
using this national security argument
and in supporting some of his own moves
so it's only been used twice in the past
and and so it's a very rarely used
section of the of the the trade act and
it's been he's been using them well
first it's been an investigation by the
Department of Commerce which concluded
that there was a national security
threat but it's worth mentioning that
the Department of Defense actually
weighed in and said that no no no no no
they have everything they need they only
need three percent of the domestic
production when it comes to steal and
it's it's also I mean there's this
rhetoric about you know are still
domestic still being hollowed and being
depleted and being you know eradicated I
mean seventy percent of the steel
consumed in the u.s. is domestic steel
and it's been going on for decades
it's the import of steel as anywhere
between 25 and 30 percent and it varies
but it's it's no more so it's a it's a
big consumption of so
the risk of this is like using this
section which indeed gives the president
tremendous flexibility and flexibility
to give success to give excitement
exemptions but under considerations that
are actually not that the Department of
Defense's know a lot of trade experts
says we're going to be dragged before
the WTO and will likely lose so it's
really self defeated
Scott Scott Paul senator corker the
Foreign Relations Committee is one who
would like to have a bill in the Senate
to require congressional approval when
this national security issue is raised
is that a good idea and what is
Congress's role in general in this area
of tariffs the way senator corker
proposed it is a terrible idea
particularly if there's an urgency to a
national security matter giving Congress
the role of being the decider and that I
think is very very dangerous territory
now let's take a step back I mean the
Constitution gives the Congress
authority over trade matters they have
ceded a lot of that improbably
rightfully so to the executive branch to
negotiate with with trade partners they
do that through trade expansion but also
through trade enforcement mechanisms
like section 232 there was it there is a
provision in Section 232 that applies to
petroleum products that lets Congress
have what's called a resolution of
disapproval after the fact but it goes
through a normal procedure when senator
corker is proposing here is essentially
providing some sort of pre authorization
by the Congress to proceed with this
which is a which would tilt the playing
field back I will say and and I know you
hear this from callers I mean there's a
lot of frustration with trade policy in
the United States and people feel like
our industries haven't been defended in
the end that our workers aren't sharing
and the benefits of all of this having
the Congress step in and say to the
president no you can't do this I think
is only going to intensify this feeling
among voters I think that there would
there should be a sense of how do we
reach some accommodation as we move
forward I would like to see more clarity
about what the administration's strategy
is on this but I do
think they deserve the benefit of the
doubt as they proceed with let's get a
response so I agree with Scott that I
think overall it's been a really good
thing to actually delegate for Congress
to delegate the trade authority to the
president who in theory represents the
nation and as such is less subjected to
special interest now the reason why we
see this push for Congress taking back
some of its power is because some of the
rhetoric from the Trump administration
is actually making people feel that
actually this is not the case in this
particular case he's very he's very he's
listening to special interest and the
steel and the steel industry in
particular and Congress for the first
time it's actually saying something that
we very rarely talk about is we always
talk about the interests of the worker
and the producers but we never talk
about the consumers and trade is not
just about workers and producers it's
also about consumers and so commerce is
effectively hearing constantly about
people in downstream industries that are
going to be hurt quite dramatically some
of them and and they're saying okay
maybe it's time to kind of you know
think of them I have to get back to
calls Gladys Illinois thank you for
waiting democratic line good morning
good morning
like hi you know I think that you all
are missing the big picture
I am the America that the American
people they know what I want actually
they don't have a clue but that's what
they say when this stuff all started the
corporations and businesses what's it in
everything over to China everybody
talking about China they said everything
over there they didn't want to play the
pay me a decent salary so they said I'm
over there where they could get stuff
done for down 25
and now everybody is saying who with the
tears over their Silla Terrace on that
well America will be doing it too they
will be doing it too if you if they had
all the stuff over in a country and you
wanted it you're not going to get it
freaking you're not going to get it on a
limited basis GLaDOS thank you sorry to
cut you off I think we understood the
points cop all what did you hear they're
from glass well I think a lot of
concerns that many Americans are
expressing which is we have a we have a
very imbalanced relationship with China
and there is strong evidence that
China's emergence and again China can
have its own Development Goals but when
they spill over and have impact on other
countries I think that that's where you
have to step in and and and push back a
bit and we haven't done a good job of
that we have a bilateral trade deficit
with China and goods of about 375
billion dollars a year there's strong
evidence economists at MIT have done
this that the the shock of Chinese
imports coming in the United States
really hollowed out a lot of these
industrial communities I'm from a town
in the Midwest in Indiana and we've seen
the auto parts and a lot of other
industries that have just that have just
vanished and there is low unemployment
in the country right now so you can't
find a job but can you find a good job
and I think that's something that a lot
of Americans are struggling with right
now and when you've lost 55,000
factories when you've lost a third of
your manufacturing appointment
employment in about 15 years I think
that that provides some of the
explanation around why you feel this
this this gap and this divide we have in
our nation right now let's hear from
Dawn in Fairfax Virginia Republican hi
Don hi how are you doing well I'd like
I'd like to ask mr. Paul a question
earlier he seemed to indicate that the
tariffs cost very little you know
consumers will pay very much
but then he boasted about how the
tariffs caused the capacity of the steel
industry to rise I wonder where does he
think those resources to build up the
steel industry come from they're not
free they don't fall out of the sky
so I'd like to hear you
excuse me where they come from all right
Scott Paul it's a fair question and I
would say first of all I mean obviously
the the the the mechanism won't work
unless prices rise there's no question
about that I mean that's how that's how
the theory works I think the real
question is who absorbs it who bears the
cost and and what is the what happens
four or five years down the road and so
if the steel industry is able to add
capacity in the United States add supply
that will have a mitigating impact on
price the other point that I that I
wanted to make and I want to make this
very strongly is that again a many
large-scale consumers of aluminum and
steel in the United States have received
extraordinary benefits over the last 15
years from excess capacity in China
they've essentially had a discount sale
and whether they've passed along those
cuts to compute consumers I mean I drank
a six-pack of beer occasionally I didn't
notice the price of the beer go down
when aluminum costs went down four or
five years ago
anheuser-busch and those other companies
they they kept that and they didn't
return it to consumers their
shareholders I think they're probably
feeling pretty good about it but this
idea that it's the end-use consumer
that's going to suffer from this I think
is fallacious let's hear from Veronique
guruji and yet first the way to get rid
of excess capacity is lowering prices
not raising them that's basic law of
economics but also it's we know that if
we put the tariffs on jobs will be lost
in the US and so we're we're like in the
stillness tree vii repeat 70% of the
steel consumed in the US is domestic
still a lot of the jobs reduction is the
product over the years of innovation
which leads to higher productivity and
higher wages right and so if we want to
lay the blame for for some job loss in
the US
we need to to competition domestic and
an international but mostly to
innovation which benefits workers and
when you put those tariffs as a response
to something that is barely a result of
trade and you're going to have really
strong distortion that will hurt
American workers
it will there's just it's there's no way
there's just no way around it and those
jobs they're not coming back and there's
also a reason why increasing you know
steel capacity requires a lot of capital
and investors may not look at actually
the landscape in the US and and
investing and steel as the right way to
go and enter and a high return on their
investment so we're doing all of this
we're doing all of this - if you said if
if - something which we know from
experience of the past is not going to
materialize and and a lot of jobs will
be lost in the process and it's sad we
say good morning to Nina who was in
keansburg New Jersey Republican caller
hello there good morning thank you for
taking my call I just want to say I back
our president completely he knows what
he's doing
I trust him completely it's about time
we had a real man out there that calls
it like it is okay and I have another
question
mm-hmm the uranium that Hillary sold to
Russia the money went on foundation not
back to the people
I mean maybe somebody out there knows
what happened to that money I'm still
waiting for them to help haiti with that
foundation so nina thank you for calling
marinade originated to that first point
support of a president Trump there's a
tweet as well from someone identifies as
Sigmund Freud but they say that former
presidents refused to take the tough
line with our trading partners friends
or foes Trump has shown a lot more
courage than any of them goes on to say
the globalists that have been trying to
steal our treasure take advantage of our
hard work are shocked so the way I think
I don't see it as courage
to actually threaten to do to put in
place a policy that will hurt the
American people and Trump allegiance
should be to the American people now
it's theirs there's a case to be made
that going back to the negotiation table
and and talking about everyone lowers
their tariffs way because and this is by
the way the way the US has led the world
towards more free trade and more trade
and more benefit shared benefit for
everyone is actually by being some time
at time unilaterally a free trade
country and so I I think that it's one
thing to say let's go to the negotiation
table and all agree to lower our tariffs
together but I don't see at all the
point of President Trump saying you
Canada you are hurting your consumer by
forcing them to buy dairy from the US
that is higher in price than it would be
without tariffs and as such my
punishment for you is that I'm going to
punish American consumers of steel
aluminum and automobile and a lot of
other things this is a logic that I
think makes no sense but it is born out
of the fact that a lot of people when
they think about trade they think export
is good and import is bad and they fail
to see the impact on consumers well hear
from Scott Paul but here's the tweet
that the president put out midweek Prime
Minister Trudeau's being so indignant
bringing up the relationship that the US
and Canada had over the many years and
all sorts of other things but he doesn't
bring up the fact that they charges 300
percent
Andheri hurting our farmers killing our
agriculture want to give you a chance to
respond everything sure well I look I
think that the challenge and in a
perfect world what veronik says is is
right but we don't live in a perfect
world in fact we live a world where you
have China is a major manufacturer it is
a state-led industry which means it
doesn't meet market norms and so you can
throw your theory out the book basically
and the and when you have a country that
produces way too much of a product like
steel
aluminum that has a massive distortive
effect on the market and on behaviors of
other governments and even though it's
kind of gone right under the headlines
one of the impact of these steel and
aluminum tariffs and again I don't think
ultimately they need to be applied to
Canada but Justin Trudeau never talked
about steel dumping from China before
now he does and he has for the last two
months the European Union has
established a safeguard on imported
steel from China that may be spilling
into their market now that it's not
going to be coming into the American
market and so it is a I will be the
first to admit that this is an imperfect
strategy the perfect strategy is to have
this international alignment and there
was some attempt to do that in the Obama
administration it reached the level of
dialogue but we are years away before
the global community is prepared to have
some sort of coordinated response to
this I think this is the United States
saying we need to have some leadership
on this we've reached a breaking point
and let's all get together and do this
and again I think that there are a lot
of downsides to the approach but it was
long overdue long overdue to have this
question called verbal can I just say on
farm on dairy we have the United States
has a surplus with Canada for dairy
products so no Canada Canadians
consumers are not killing our market
they are penalized because their
government make them pay way more for it
than they would if they didn't have
tariffs I'm gonna get over to Jim Mount
Morris Michigan Republican hi Jim
hey did Lori thank you for taking my
call welcome yep yep my opinion is uh
when I graduated high school back in 78
mmm in the newspaper there was up to
three pages both sides of general labor
do to get a job of factories all over
the place and they paid good benefits
and after that free trade agreement came
in the NAFTA I mean it was just
unbelievable how everything disappeared
and what you guys today I
believe is you know preity percent of
our population is not college material
whether or not they have the aptitude
for it or the the money to be able to do
it or and what the heck is these people
gonna do I mean back then you know you
were able to take care of your families
have a car go on vacation and all this
stuff and you know with that NAFTA just
sucked all of our jobs out of our
country and with this president excuse
me with this president you know I see
him trying to get some of this stuff
back whether it's tariffs or
renegotiating this nafta thing and to
see something wrong with that I just I
just don't get it man because you know
if you ain't as old as me and seen what
it was like then no that's where I get
to make America great again same for all
is theirs when I grew up Jim thank you
for calling Jim mentioning Mexico there
reminds us to talk about NAFTA we've
been talking about Canada as part of the
the g7 but but explain for us well we
hear from both of you beginning with
Scott Paul where do you see the NAFTA
negotiations going we know the president
is talking about just bilateral deals
and not a a broader deal but where do
you see this headed yeah and here I am
referring back to something veronik said
before is there's the president says
something wet ultimately happens it is
anyone's guess and and I'm I've been
terrible about making predictions about
what this administration is going to do
as everybody I think but I do think I
mean there was a sense of urgency to try
to reach a NAFTA deal based on the
Congressional calendar or some political
realities that I think has appeared to
have passed and so I do think that there
are a number of places in modernizing
the agreement that the three countries
have reached reached some common
principles there's still some issues out
there to work on the the the idea of
lifting up wages in Mexico is one of
those to create a consumer class in
Mexico that can buy more American
products as well that's one issue what
constitute a NAFTA made automobile
that's another issue and so it's gonna
take a little bit of time for them to
work through this I do think that
there's a common interest in getting a
deal done particularly because I think
this is the president's position we
either need a new deal or no deal at all
and I think that there are a lot of
downsides to not have a model for
economic integration in in North America
so I think it's important that we do get
a new deal but one that's a lot more
beneficial like the caller said to two
workers and that we can have more
production Beranek division so I think
there's room for improvement and and and
the NAFTA deal of course but I I think
the way the president is going about it
this is I would not I wouldn't be able
to tell you where actually we stand up
at this point on this but I think this
it's a terrible idea and this is one of
the problem actually with as much as I'm
a big supporter of multilateral
agreements this is terrible idea for the
u.s. to demand that we export our back
wage laws and labor laws by forcing the
forcing minimum wage laws into into the
Canadian market which may actually do a
lot of damage a to to lower income
Mexican in the name that they ought to
buy are things one of the things that
economists have found over and over and
over again is that when we import more
we export more we don't need to be
bossing around other countries and
exporting our bad labor laws making
their labor market less flexible in the
name of buying more of our stuff and so
I think I think there's a big there's a
there's a big risk there and and and I
hope we're gonna get a deal on NAFTA
because NAFTA is actually an extremely
it was extremely beneficial to Americans
Mexican and Canadian alike I mean you
and and and it is true the color is
right I mean the nature
Manufacturing job has changed quite
dramatically but if even with we hadn't
had any trade with anyone some of these
changes would have happened quite
dramatically too because of innovation
because it is in the nature the nature
of companies they have to compete at
least domestically and one way that they
do it is becoming more productive and
and yes it means it changes the nature
of jobs if you go to a steel factory now
it's they're amazing they look nothing
like they would they look 30 years ago
they're clean there and and it is true
it's not high school grads that that
work in these Steel's
and this is why these manufacturing jobs
look very appealing is because they're
they're well paid but it's you know you
can't have it both ways
let's get a call from Orlando democratic
lines sandy for our two guests a loss
Andy hello Scott do you represent does
your Alliance is it to represent all
American manufacturing we we're a
partnership between the United Steel
Workers Union which is North America's
largest industrial union and some heavy
manufacturers including some in the
steel sector okay well maybe my question
has been more related to if president
Trump wants to you know show advancement
in trade
why do you both think that he doesn't
bring his businesses or Ivanka's
businesses back from China to be
manufactured in the United States what
what precipitates him from not doing
that Thank You sandy couple so I am
wearing a Brooks Brothers tie that's
made in Long Island City New York which
the president can probably have almost
seen from Trump Tower when he lived
there and so it is a and it's a
profitable company and it's able to make
a tie in the United States of America I
mean the truth is that most garments and
textiles coming in the United States are
imported the vast majority over 90
but if you if you make it your business
model it's actually possible to try to
to try to try to have a profitable
business and the president just never
chose that path and I do think that it's
somewhat hypocritical of him to to
expect others to do it but for him not
to do it himself and I've been clear
about that criticism
I don't think again that there's a
reason that's not a reason however to
want to have better trade agreements for
working people in the United States and
manaphy and I'm glad Verona we raised
this point I don't think the United
States should boss Mexico or Canada
around I think this has to be a mutual
agreement but so far these trade deals
have been full of lots of agreements
that have benefited multinational
corporations who are doing very well in
this model and pharmaceutical companies
patent holders but workers Minh the
brunt of this we've seen real wages be
quite stagnant particularly in what we
would call traded industries those are
industries that are subject to global
competition and part of this is this
threat to move factories to one place or
another
and so having restoring some balance and
giving workers more of a voice I think
is an important ingredient in making
trade work for everybody not only in the
United States but in other countries as
well Mike is calling from Clarksburg
West Virginia independent caller hi Mike
it's it's Frank Peter but so so it's
Frank but you're calling from West
Virginia oh yes sir
Here I am go ahead please I got been a
while so to talk to you all but I can't
stand it disappointing I'm losing it
Automation yeah a corporation is going
to send that overseas to get it made
cheaper here and there inevitably you're
going to have automation that's going to
make it you will have three people by
pushing the button run just a few things
to make the whole situation whatever
whether it's a car or an airplane or
whatever it is coal mines
take 300 million you run one on 50 so
your populations going up you want to
have less jobs accepted technology and
how many people were going to take to
run them just one but and Canada didn't
burn down the White House but y'all have
a good day anything there you want to
respond to I think it's I mean it's a
it's a very good point I mean it is it
is I mean you know innovation
labor-saving innovation has led to a
decrease in the number of jobs needed
and and also it also means that we don't
need the same number of people to work
in those plants but also we don't need
the same type of workers and again it's
worth saying this is why wages are high
in in manufacturing so with all of this
here's a headline I want to run by you
another one of the takeaways from
yesterday President Trump said in a
surprise we should at least consider no
tariffs scalp all starting with you what
is a world with no tariffs look like
well it could be a good world and so the
answer is it depends what are the other
factors here are government's actively
engaged and in the in the activities
over their industries like China is and
you have there are other sorts of trade
barriers that go beyond tariffs they're
called non-tariff trade barriers and
they take regulate and form and
regulations exchange rates make a big
difference the difference between the
dollar and other currency so so tariffs
aren't the only factor and you can't
isolate tariffs and say this is gonna
make the entire difference about whether
a country is going to be competitive or
not competitive or not so again I don't
I don't know what the president is
saying there but but what I think needs
to happen is that the the largest
nations engaged in international trade
need to need to agree to market
disciplines China has not done that and
that is an extraordinary challenge that
the United States faces as well as these
other industrial economies at the g7
Veronique de Russia the German
Chancellor Angela Merkel responded as
somewhat positively political rights to
Trump's suggestion Friday telling him
we'll take it as a starting point but
let me get to reply listen like Scott I
have no idea I mean I plus the president
and could be changing his mind like
right now as we speak and say oh just
but I yeah I'll take no tariffs and in
fact I will also take no tariffs in the
u.s. because they will mean more welfare
for the United States even if other
countries decide to continue punishing
their own consumers but my fear about
the statement by Donald Trump yesterday
is that the way thinks about it is that
gets no tariffs only if it means two
more exports to the to two other
countries and in a reduction of the
trade deficit but there's a profound
misunderstanding of the trade deficit
here I mean it's true first we're
getting a lot when we buy things from
foreigners but also what we're not
seeing is like the reason why foreigners
want to sell us things is because they
want our dollars and when you look that
the relationship between the the amount
of goods we buy and the capital that we
get back into the US as a result is
moved together so what are these guys
doing so they sell us things which
benefit our consumers and it comes back
to the US these dollars they have to
spend them they don't sit on them I mean
they may use them to trade with each
other but ultimately it will come back
here in a form of investments in the
form of buying our debt which by the way
we can see this as a negative as the
president has said but the alternative
is we need to dramatically cut spending
or we need to be willing to say we're
gonna spend the same level but interest
rates are going to be much higher so
we're gonna face more deficits so it's
just so my fear just all this to say
that I think there's a misunderstanding
by the president about the trade deficit
the trade deficit is not the fact that
we have a trade deficit with the country
is not a bad thing it's not it could be
some time to symptom of bad things but
in
itself the trade deficit is not a bad
thing and there are good things that we
get in return for it time for a couple
more calls Roger from Ahola Pennsylvania
Democratic line hi Roger
hi it's my understanding that the real
reason that the industry steel industry
went down is because they had all an old
fashioned system of producing steel
where after World War two Europe and
Japan had rebuilt with newer systems
that were cheaper and more competitive
and that it was old-fashioned
competition that hurt us and for us to
regear and I guess it's company called
new core is the only company in America
that uses the newer system and it has
nothing to do with these old-fashioned
tariffs this is all just bluster to gain
political points and the other thing is
we're at 19 trillion dollars a GDP for
us to hurt these much smaller economic
company countries the EU is at 18
trillion all combined is just again
political bluster to gain political
points and the real problems with this
country is the military-industrial
complex which is hurting us and the
medical industrial complex which is
hurting us and which obviously trump is
doesn't have the guts to to deal with
and at the brainwashing also like that
one lady was like I'm Way out of line is
the other major problem with this
country Roger thanks for calling let's
hear from our guests sure well with
respect to steel Rogers is not wrong
about what happened in the 60s and the
70s I mean Germany and Japan became
steel powers and in part they were
gifted steel industries back through the
Marshall Plan and they were more modern
and an American producers it didn't make
the kinds of changes that they needed
that was the problem in the 60s and 70s
that's not the problem today the problem
today is much different you have a
global competitor China China makes half
the world's steel its steel industry is
controlled by its government it is
only inefficient three times as much
carbon per ton of steel 40 times per you
know for a lot of other kinds of
pollutants so it's not an efficient
industry at all it from a man our
perspective it's not efficient at all
but it is completely and totally
subsidized by the Chinese government and
so if you look at it today American
steel is quite competitive from a
Productivity basis but we're losing
because China can sell essentially below
cost and you know theoretically that's
good for consumers until all the steel
mills in the United States run into
bankruptcy and you're faced with limited
supply and then it's not so great a
choice that's why you see these
interventions today my understanding of
one of the problems with a steel
industry which by the way I mean I will
really dispute this fact that the steel
industry is doing poorly in 70% again of
the steel consumed in the US is domestic
steel and when you look at you know
executive compensation in the steel
industry and there seem to be doing fine
and and so there's there's there's a lot
of there's just a lot of talking about
the steel industry name need to be
protecting but I don't see it in in the
data I plus you know competition is good
and one of the problem with the steel
industry historically has been that it's
always been protected it's always been
protected - one way or another and it is
actually the reason why it wasn't
adjusting as fast and modernizing as
fast it's because it was protecting
protected and companies that are
protected by governments one way or
another either by blocking competition
or by getting subsidized just don't
adjust as well one last call will from
Crossville Tennessee independent caller
hi well thank you back when I went to
work in the sixties the companies
trained you to do the job I hear these
news men all the time I find that
they've got no skill trades and there
was not enough workforce while training
like they used to sit right there
running their mouths you know I mean why
don't they train at home
job I could do this instead of crying
and won't nobody else going debt for
$100 to our thousand dollar get
education to do it all right well thank
you we have time for one final thought
on the president's trade policies let's
start with the marinade do regime I
think there's a lot of you know
blistering and a lot of you know it if
they change also it's worth saying that
within the administration there's a lot
of divide on one hand you have Secretary
of Treasury Steve minuchin and and the
head of the National Economic Council
Larry Kudlow who are free traders and on
the other hand you have the Department
of Commerce Wilbur Ross and and the
economic advisor Peter Navarro who are
very NT trade so you get a lot of
different messages but the thing that's
worrisome in my opinion is like if you
look at something that the president has
said consistently over the last thirty
years I mean when you look at all of it
it's been on trade he actually believes
he actually believes that trade is is a
zero-sum game one person wins one person
loses and unfortunately I mean and
thankfully it's not correct the trade is
a win-win it's a win-win situation it's
a win-win policy even though sometimes
you actually don't see the winners and
everything that the president wants to
do will actually hurt the Americans if
implemented again I comment if he really
wants to go back to the negotiation
table and try to say let's all become
the most free trader we've ever been
great but I'm afraid that if this is the
case this is not the way to go and and
that this is not what he has in mind
Dan Scott ball I think we need a smart
and strategic approach from the
president as we move forward I think
that there's good evidence that the
tariffs are having their desired effect
you've seen just this week another steel
mill announced that it was reopening a
blast furnace in Granite City Illinois a
place I visited a few times there needs
to be this disruption because there has
been
an imbalance but I don't agree with the
president that trade wars are easy to
win and I don't think that ultimately
they're a good thing I think that
tariffs can be effective and there's
good evidence for that one of the
reasons why we have automobiles from
Japanese company made in the United
States today instead of all of them
coming from Japan there was pressure in
the Reagan impression or a semiconductor
industry in the United States because
there was pressure and so there is a
there's a blueprint on how to do it but
it has to be smart and it has to be
strategic our guests have been Scott
Paul president of the Alliance for men
American manufacturing and Veronique
darou J the senior research fellow at
the Mercatus Center at George Mason
University thanks a lot for joining us
for this hour all your insight and all
the information about trade and
terrorists appreciate it
thank you